all right it is time for drew's news
your daily peel of the good news string
cheese gosh i love string chicken
well with me at the desk is my main news
squeeze rossi rasmathia bye everybody hi
hello i went yellow i loved the yellow
you know i've been trying to brighten up
my color palette because i do see that
it has an effect on my overall mood
well yellow yellow
also i'm really excited about the news
today because we have a very special
guest and he's actually going to talk
about this really cool project that he
has but you already know him from his
eight seasons on saturday night live
and now he's taking over saturday
morning cartoons with his new netflix
series called saturday morning all-star
hits it's really cool take a look
welcome to smash i'm skip and i'm trebor
and we're
we gotta get back because we can't miss
an all-new stronghold yeah cause i do a
voice on it
god i'm so excited please
[Applause]
i know i
yes okay so i'm really excited about
saturday morning um cartoons that you're
doing because i grew up with saturday
morning cartoons and i understand that
you are a vhs collector yeah and it's
like mixed media yeah it's called it's
called saturday morning all-star hits
it's on netflix i i it's my favorite
thing i've ever gotten to make and yes
this is stuff that is sort of ingrained
in me and yeah i have a pretty big vhs
collection like
at snl which could be a pretty stressful
job we used to always
after shows after the after party at
like 5 00 a.m 5 00 a.m people would come
over to my apartment and then i'd throw
on like a popples tape or like jam or
gem rainbow brite
or thunder cats yes thunder cats
i saw one nod yeah
they know you guys watch saturday
morning cartoons when you're growing up
you know they know
um it just is so joyful and delightful
congratulations
[Applause]
yeah well kyle
would you um do us the honor and hit
some headlines with us yes i'm get i
will i'm going to be i'm an honor
bye-bye
well first up the fantastic meryl streep
is like an onion and we just love
peeling back her layers because cnn
reports that meryl shocked her don't
look up co-star jennifer lawrence and
the rest of the world when she revealed
she was watching the real housewives of
beverly hills oh meryl now jayla herself
we have known um is a
very loyal fan
of reality television and michelle obama
eddie redmayne michael rappaport rihanna
all these people have fessed up too this
is their happy place
and um meryl streep is joining that list
too
kyle is there anything you watch to just
get out of in spo mode and escape well
say i don't i don't watch this
particular show but knowing that merrell
watches it
if by watching it i become more like
meryl streep sure
i will begin watching yes
it's like the meryl streep stamp of
approval
i'll do anything i'll do i certainly
feel better about my poor television
choices like i watch so much 90 day if
my fiance if merrell can watch right you
guys watch it if merrill watches beverly
hills households i basically have an
oscar that's the like
that's the logic in my head because
we're basically the same person meryl
thank you
that's all we love you thank you we love
you
rock your story all right well next
we've got some fun surprises on the
prada runway at the milan fashion week
insider reports prada's body of work
line included models that you may have
seen before jeff goldblum and kyle
mclaughlin all the models were actors
all of them thomas brodie sangster from
um the queen's gambit you know uh asa
butterfield from sex education and jaden
michael uh from colin in black and white
we love who's been on the show
absolutely love they were all models um
kyle any modeling aspirations do you
think maybe you could be
i tell myself there's nothing i can't do
um and if that's what the world wants to
see
if that's what they've been waiting for
i'm willing i'm telling you now america
thank you
i'm ready to do it get me out on that
catwalk i want to show you what i'm made
of oh really you you want to show us
what you're made of because we got a
little runway right here
[Applause]
should we walk towards a specific way or
yeah walk walk right over here
make love to the camera
that's good
that's good
oh i love that he looks cute yeah
[Applause]
hit it okay
[Applause]
drew
[Applause]
um first of all kyle i'm just gonna say
i thought you looked really handsome and
cute especially like this i realized
like guys do do that and you pulled the
like it's true that's what guys do and
it looks good i know i don't know what
do you mean
it just came naturally thank you
kyle will you take our next story oh yes
next if you're sitting at home looking
for something good to celebrate today
we've got you covered this is
every day is a holiday
yesterday was tin can day tomorrow is
hug day
but today is something very special
it's national cheese lovers day
so everybody
grab your cheese hats
oh
um
[Applause]
oh and look look oh we got gouda to
cheddar to
camera bear
rossi drew think fast you can only eat
one cheese for the rest of your life
what do you pick oh hands down goat
cheese would be my number one cheese of
all time i love it goat cheese parmesan
what's your all-time favorite cheese
drew macaroni and cheese right
so i'm just munching here
kyle if you could only have one cheese
for the rest of your life
jack
yeah we got pepperjack lovers in the
audience
[Music]
you